So up to this point, we've actually talked quite
a bit about the non-coding regions of our genome.
>> Promoters, enhancers, and silencers are just
a portion of the non-coding piece of
the pie. There's a lot of other ways that gene expression can be regulated.
>> Exactly. There's some really cool ways, like how
DNA wraps around histone proteins. Remember histones are actually those
proteins that organize DNA into chromosomes. You can modify those
histones that, in a way that actually promotes or inhibits
transcription of a gene. There are also these small RNAs called micro
RNAs that can bind to an MRNA transcript and target it for destruction.
>> Now if you're interested in learning more about this topic we
strongly encourage you to seek out a higher level genetics class or
do some reading on your own. But for us, I just want
you to focus on the non-coding
regions called promoters, enhancers, and silencers.
>> And regulatory proteins, such as transcription factors.